you're watching swipe coming up on this
week's show Chris sits down with the man
dubbed the Steven Spielberg of gaming
what animal shot this footage and
Alyssia joins the Pokemon go crazy
because let's face it who hasn't hello
and welcome to swipe if you're a gamer
you will have heard of Hideo Kojima if
you're not a gamer he's the man behind
one of gaming's biggest franchises Metal
Gear he came to the UK this week and
Chris managed to get an interview with
him to find out what makes him tick
Hideo Kojima is described by some is the
Steven Spielberg of gaming No
his Metal Gear series is critically and
commercially acclaimed selling nearly 50
million copies worldwide the games are
known for their elaborate plots complex
characters and focus on the supernatural
good I do you got on I don't think of my
games it's dark I'm trying to make them
more realistic dude when I started
making games thirty years ago they was
involved and really sztyc characters had
no background there was no real story
day so I made it my mission to depict
these elephants with the story what
would occur though you do I didn't want
my characters to be lines of code you
know I wanted them to be living organic
things I also wanted to convey the
struggles that these characters have
been through some of the more difficult
background they have had you don't know
so I see this not as adding darker
that's not gamer but rather adding dead
or last year Kojima left the games
developer Konami where he'd been since
the 80s to set up his own studio and
back and at e3 he teased the game he's
currently working on death stranding
it's a collaboration with actor Norman
Reedus film and television have had a
big influence on Kojima's career
oh my eggo me too I love film but there
are two big reasons I watch movies to
help me still - you don't wanna watch it
we do this one is that they show me
things I don't know about people the
worlds and eras that spark my creativity
to make games the other reason would be
the energy making games is a long
process it can be very difficult at
times with a lot of struggles
I mean interview - Colonel gamers look
good in which she join me if I'm going
through a difficult patch and I watch a
great movie it reminds me there are so
many creative people out there all over
the world pushing hard to accomplish
great things that really motivates all
to keep going so I guess these are the
two reasons why I make sure I watch
movies every day really do and of course
video games themselves are an important
influence - what would you say is your
favorite game of all time
what's my character was nobody I know
gonna yoke any Hydra - on that game
that's the question that I get often -
but I guess the one that influenced me
the most the one I played before joining
this industry was Super Mario Brothers
what a jump can I own this done but I
see dooshka it's a sin
okay I'll give them do this jump and run
you have two buttons within it's a side
scroller and that's it there's nothing
more to it but just by adding the
element having time when you use those
actions the game gained so much depth
you are the diesel it's the game that I
played the most in my life
I played hundreds of hours of it and
it's the one that made me realize the
possibilities to gaming hands I don't
think I've seen another that surpasses
that word my muddled mother lays with
the rise of mobile gaming titles like
Pokemon go for example do you think
that's changing the way people engage
with games do you think it means that
less people are going to play the sort
of long immersive games really big
narratives that you're famous for got a
book Dave do you game I once made a game
in the past called boktai papers for
Game Boy Advance had a UV sensor and the
way this game works was that you had to
use real-life solar power under the
vampires in the game the interaction
with the real world in a way is kind of
like the way Pokemon go works so now I
have to go over there someone it's
important to look at how you can use new
technology to expand your options I
don't think this year kind of thing is a
replacement for the Marlins and I don't
think if something new comes along you
say okay this is the new thing and it's
the only thing we do do on the contrary
I think the more options we get the
wider variety of games we can say
critical data cotton on this hog or
shooting Costera noisy well so what do
you think about the current state of the
UK games industry well mark Peters
numbers hey boys first off British music
is awesome it's the best music in the
world it is they are so British movies
are also fantastic when it comes to
games I never put much attention into
where the game is strong but if I had to
answer that question about a specific
British company with um would if you
were I would have to say Media Molecule
they are really great
Oh Stoughton Leakey need a tailor to you
cup I feel like they have a completely
different environment and philosophy
what style of making games is very
different from any other place kinds
your students know what they're making
right now I don't even know if you could
call it a game but it's something I'm
not able to imitate the way they express
what they're making something that I
guess you could call original you can't
find anywhere else I'm on marketing the
shieldon or there are many studios
outside that led by marketing support
but for them it's very difficult or more
common to go does yoga what do you think
the future will hold for virtual reality
do you think it could have as much of an
impact on the gaming industry as the
jump from 2d to 3d did for example when
the world was little more originally I
think when technology changed from 2d to
3d essentially stayed the same as movies
and TV you always restricted to this
frame to this square frame but now the
frame is gone so I think it will make an
even bigger difference than the jump to
3d and I don't think that this change
will only be in games eventually it will
make it into changing our overall
lifestyle it might start in games but
soon it will have a deep penetration in
society that is when we will realize the
true value of the technology it's
impossible to know how gaming technology
will evolve in the years to come but if
anyone has a good idea it's the man
who's been at the forefront of all its
changes so far Chris Krieg and Sky News
stay with us still to come we've got the
mobile game everyone's going on about
but before then here's a roundup of some
of this week's tech news forget Google
Streetview take a look at cheap view 360
small handheld 360 degree cameras have
been attached to sheep tin the Faroe
Islands to help map out the landscape
it's after locals said Google won't send
its own camera cars there the sheep who
apparently outnumber people in the Faroe
Islands graze around as normal while the
cameras take images that the tourists
bought then uploads to Google Street
View
Pokemon go arrived in the UK this week
after proving a massive hit in the
States but it's not without controversy
the mobile game has players wandering
around in real life while capturing
virtual monsters in locations around
them before the UK release some reports
from America suggested criminals were
using the game to lead players to remote
areas to rob them there's more on
Pokemon go in our games review who knew
wild coral-like a good smoochy a new
underwater microscope camera has
captured what researchers think is coral
exchanging materials while embracing the
advanced camera that films
high-resolution millimeter scale footage
also managed to capture coral turf wars
and the first stages of algae taking
over bleached reefs now it's time for
our regular game slot and taking us
through the titles this week is Alysha
so you may have noticed wandering around
the streets a lot of people staring at
their phones slightly more than normal
and other people staring wistfully at
them as they stare at their phones
that's because there's a game called
Pokemon go that's out it's the dream
game where it uses augmented reality to
turn you into an actual pokemon trainer
so you can run around your town staring
at your phone and if you lift up the
camera Pokemon will appear in front of
you and you can just by using the
touchscreen flick little pokeballs at
them and catch them suddenly people are
running around their neighborhood it's
gaming on the go a lot of people joking
that there's something moving around
outside their house the app actually
works by using your GPS so there are
different kind of settlements and areas
that the app picks up on if you're near
a park then a lot of grass type Pokemon
will appear if you're near a river or
the sea a lot of water type Pokemon will
appear and it takes certain landmarks to
say your local pub or a station on the
corner and it turns them into kind of
poker points where you can visit them
and get certain items and there are also
gyms so if you beat the Pokemon that's
sat in your local gym you become basic
the gym leader for your town in your
areas there's a lot of competitive play
next up is inside and it's kind of the
successors from the same studio as the
guys who made a game called limbo it's
the brand-new game where once again
you're playing a little boy who he wakes
up in a wilderness everything's trying
to kill him but unlike limbo where the
main antagonist was a giant spiders
there was lots of fantasy elements this
time it's very gritty it's very real the
people who are trying to kill you aren't
men in masks in this kind of dystopian
horror world where the threat is a lot
more tangible
it's a side-scrolling platformer so you
only move from left to right the whole
time across the screen and there's only
two buttons so you basically press
either to jump or to grab onto things
but that simplicity belies a really
emotional complex narrative so Monster
Hunter generations is a vast action RPG
where you run around this kind of
adventure world where monsters roam free
and like any good hunter-gatherer you
have to go out into the wilderness kill
the most powerful monsters you can and
use their skins to get better and
there's been a few changes since the
rest of kind of like the series that's
come before it so now you've got
different classes of hunters that you
can you can kind of be there's there's
four different supercharged hunter
abilities that you can whack out in
battle so if you're battling a
particularly tough monster you can
unleash a devastating wave of damage or
you can heal your teammates because you
can either play this single player on
your Nintendo DS or you can team up with
four other people and go around and take
out as many monsters as you can
that's it for this week take a good look
at signings on mobile tablet catch up
sky queue and snapchat for all the
latest tech stories throughout the week
and we'll see you again next week
bye-bye